presidential primaries and caucuses the
electoral foreplay that we've been
engaging in since February which will
culminate in the mass balloon
ejaculations of this summer's
conventions both parties nearly have
their nominee and it looks like America
will be choosing between Donald Trump
America's walking talking brushfire and
in all likelihood Hillary Clinton the
woman who exhibits either too much or
too little of every human quality
depending on who you ask which is not to
say that the Democrats primary process
is over as we saw in Nevada last weekend
it is very much still raging this is
ridiculous this whole process emotions
ran high at the Democratic state
convention in Las Vegas after Hillary
Clinton took more delicate ones and
Bernie Sanders Saturday
holy usually when a crowd is that
angry in Vegas it's because they just
realize there are no elephants in Cirque
de Soleil just a bunch of terrifying
nightmare perverts but but it's not just
Nevada that is caused frustration over
how delegates are assigned throughout
this process thanks to an odd quirk in
the democrat system there have been news
reports like this we're putting up right
now a graphic Bernie Sanders wins 56 to
44 percent in Wyoming the delegates
rewarded Hillary Clinton 11 Bernie
Sanders 7 why does the Democratic Party
even have voting booths know why his
system is so rigged oh please
we have voting booths for the same
reason that Friendly's has restaurant
booths so that we can have relative
privacy while we choose from a deeply
unappetizing menu and it is not just the
Democrats when Donald Trump won
Louisiana beating Ted Cruz by more than
three percent
he was upset to discover that Cruz could
potentially get as many as 10 more
delegates or as he put it I end up
winning Louisiana and then when
everything is done I find out I get less
delegates than this guy that got his ass
kicked okay give me a break the thing is
I get why he's annoyed and there is no
clear a piece of evidence that our
system is broken
no more thoroughly dead canary in the
coalmine than when Donald Trump is
actually making sense because when you
see results like that the process does
feel counterintuitive so so tonight we
thought we'd ask why do the parties
operate this way because for many years
they didn't until 50 years ago most
states didn't even have primaries and
candidates were chosen by party insiders
at the convention but in 1968 that
system broke down when the Democratic
Party leadership picked Hubert Humphrey
despite the fact he hadn't even competed
in a primary Democrats were pissed off
and the convention was chaos a lot of
pushing the man being pushed watch it
they're going to knock that over
man is a delegate they're asking for
silence there's a priest in here dozens
of reporters and the man who got
involved in it all is very calmly
smoking his cigarette oh he's not just
smoking any cigarette he's smoking a
Chesterfield Chesterfield once you've
turned democracy into a riot
you deserve a Chesterfield in the years
that followed that nests both parties
reformed their processes to give their
rank-and-file members more of a say but
many of the details were left up to
state leaders which might help explain
why we have such an erratic
every four years almost every part of
this process is difficult to defend for
instance while most states hold
primaries in all of these states one or
both parties hold caucuses which as I'm
sure you know is a process whereby you
typically have to turn up to a certain
place at a certain time like a school
gymnasium at 7:00 p.m. attend a party
meeting that can take hours and then
vote which can be prohibitive because if
you work at night we can't get a
babysitter or you don't have
transportation you can be frozen out and
that is probably why while Republican
primary turnout in 2012 was 19% their
turnout for caucuses averaged just 3%
which is terrible if you have three
percent turnout at an orgy it's
basically just you masturbating next to
a table full of uneaten snacks so
generally generally you are lucky if you
live in a state that has a primary
unless you're a Democrat in Washington
State
where things get a little more
complicated in Washington State we have
both caucuses
and presidential primaries will you
actually cast a ballot in private but
Democrats have never liked the primary
and they've ignored it from day one it's
true the Democrats presidential primary
in Washington doesn't count they have
won and it's this Tuesday but all the
pledged delegates were decided in their
caucus months ago so you know you're
awful friend who says he doesn't vote
because he doesn't feel like his vote
counts if he's our Washington Democrat
participating in the primary he's right
he's still awful but he is right and
then there's the problem of how the
delegates get divided up which is key
because remember you're not directly
voting for a candidate you're voting to
help determine the delegates who will
attend the National Party convention and
vote for a candidate on your behalf and
some states have even more steps in
between just look at what led up to last
weekend's events in Nevada they had a
caucus back in February which Hillary
Clinton won but that caucus only
determined 23 out of their 35 regular
delegates as for the remaining 12 those
were decided by delegates at the state
convention who were chosen by the
delegates at County conventions in April
who were chosen in those February
corporate caucuses which remember
hillary won now unfortunately for her at
those County conventions more Bernie
supporters showed up so they had an
advantage going into the state
convention although by that time Hillary
supporters had realized what was
happening and have managed to mobilize
their turnout putting numbers in that
room basically even at which point both
sides began fighting to disqualify one
another's delegates over technicalities
such as failing to register as Democrats
by May the first a deadline set after it
had already passed at the convention by
the credentials committee and at this
point whoever you support you probably
feel like this exactly I just don't know
if there's a better servation of this
entire primary process so far than that
sound now for the record
PolitiFact looked into the charges of
rigging in Nevada and found no clear
evidence the state party hijacked the
process and you can disagree with that
as I am sure Bernie supporters will in
the comments section below this video
alongside hurtful remarks about my
personal appearance like oh look it's
British Milhouse or he looks like
someone who says my parents are my best
friends but who's also an orphan or did
someone just Benjamin Button Henry
Kissinger all of which statements
politifact also rates as true but but
the larger point
PolitiFact made regarding Nevada though
I think everyone can agree with is the
archein party structures don't reflect
how most people assume presidential
selection works and that in itself is a
huge problem any competition should have
clear rules you don't get to the end of
a football game and say okay who founds
the most eggs wait what that's what we
were supposed to be doing why didn't
someone tell me that at the start I only
have five eggs and look this this
patchwork of convoluted systems would be
annoying enough but each party also has
its own way of potentially putting its
thumb on the scale for Democrats it's
super-delegates about 15% of the total
delegates to this summer's Democratic
convention are unpledged these are
elected officials former presidents and
assorted party bigwigs called
super-delegates they can vote for
whichever candidate they want regardless
of who won in their state or district
okay so the delegates are super in the
way the kids on my super sweet 16 are
super they are party obsessed widely
resented and untethered from all
responsibilities now the theory behind
super-delegates was that the party
leaders could step in if they didn't
like the way things were heading which
is what makes it so weird that whenever
debbie Wasserman Schultz the chair of
the DNC is asked about them she insists
that super-delegates would never do that
look we have party activists elected
officials and other leaders that are a
part of our process but who have never
determined the outcome of our nominee
yeah but if they're not going to make a
difference then why take the risk of
having them at all
you're basically keeping rat poison in a
jar next to the sugar saying hey it
hasn't been a problem yet
that might technically be true but is
this really the best system you can
think of meanwhile Republicans have
their own way of diluting the power of
primary votes in many states delegates
are only required to reflect their
state's choice in the first round of
convention voting after that they become
unbound delegates and can vote for
whomever they want and Pennsylvania
takes this even further out of their 71
delegates 54 are completely unbound even
on the first ballots
and while these delegates are elected by
voters those voters may not know what
they're actually voting for if you're a
GOP voters you well know which candidate
you are choosing when you step into the
voting booth but when it comes to
choosing delegates to the presidential
convention there's no way for you to
know which ones support which candidates
because it's simply not listed like your
vote but who are you voting for
you have no idea if don't see with the
Stars had a system where instead of
voting directly for Paige Vanzant or
ginger Zee you had to vote for Doug or
Karen to vote on your behalf neither of
whom will tell you which dancer they
prefer there would be riots in the
streets and it gets one-step crazy
because this year North Dakota
Republicans just said it and had
neither a caucus nor a primary the party
just chose 28 Delegates themselves and
in explaining why primaries aren't that
important one of those delegates kind of
gave the whole game away in previous
years we've used primaries to probably
get us some kind of an indication of the
preference of the population but the
delegates at the convention choose a
nominee not the voters in the primaries
so basically he's treating the more than
27 million people who voted so far in
the Republican primaries like a parent
treats a kid with a toy lawnmower oh
great job Billy you did it all your own
now step aside daddy's coming through
to repair to both parties
they're basically private clubs they can
set their own rules in theory they could
give the nomination to whichever
candidate comes first alphabetically or
whichever one can squeeze a frog the
hardest without crushing it but if you
play by a system of complex opaque rules
that almost nobody understands and that
you could use your advantage even if you
don't you are going to alienate voters
this is a system which clearly needs
wholesale reform the problem is once the
system produces a winner
the conversation tends to just move on
and if you need any more proof of that
just listen to Trump earlier this month
you've been hearing me say it's a rigged
system but now I don't say it anymore
because I want ok it's quick nobody
wants to change the weird rules if they
win you think the producers of the
Martian are complaining about the rules
by which the Golden Globes actually gave
them Best Motion Picture comedy or
musical no of course not
they're just busy writing another movie
as side-splitting Lee hilarious as Matt
Damon potato farming in space for two
hours it would clearly behoove both
parties to take a long hard look at this
because they actually got lucky this
time
whether you like these two candidates or
not it does seem the party nominees will
coincidentally be the people with the
most votes Trump currently has a lead of
nearly four million over his closest
competitor and Hillary leads Sanders by
over three million and Sanders
supporters might argue that doesn't
include all caucus votes but when the
Washington Post estimated the rest they
found that she would still lead by two
point nine million votes and even if you
multiply all those estimated caucus
votes by seven to account for lower
turnout even if you give Bernie a bonus
of 10,000 extra votes in every state
that's voted so far and even if you tack
on an extra hundred thousand votes just
for shits and giggles she's still
comfortably ahead and I know Bernie
supporters I can hear you typing right
now
I can hear you typing but I look like an
angry toucan funded by ciliary but that
doesn't make that any less true but the
problem is there is no gap there's no
guarantee that the candidate with the
most votes will win next time and if
they don't all the floors we just
documented will be exposed yet again
because unfortunately we only get angry
about the primary process during the
primary process when it's impacting the
candidate that we care about but the
middle of the game is the worst possible
time to change the rules so if everyone
is as angry as they say they are right
now let's together
pick a date early next year to actually
write an email to the chair of each
party and remind them politely to fix
this I proposed February 2nd now that
will be easy to remember because it's
Groundhog Day which does seem
appropriate because unless this primary
process is fixed we are all destined to
live through the same nightmare scenario
over and over again until the end of
King time
you